[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vue une
émission où l'on débat de l'actualité et
l'actualité du jour c'est la polémique
sur les propos d' emmanuel macron le mot
bordel puisque c'est celui-là est ce que
vocabulaire d'un président jupiter ou
d'un président vulgaire on va en parler
pendant ce temps là jean luc mélenchon
essaye lui de faire descendre les
étudiants dans la rue lafrance insoumise
mobiliser les facs contre la politique
du gouvernement
aura-t-elle plus de succès qu'avec les
salariés on va le voir lui n'est plus
prof à nanterre et en principe il ne
fait plus de politique mais cela ne
l'empêchent pas de reprendre du service
c'est dominique strauss kahn qui vient
de se rappeler au bon souvenir des
manuels macron on verra comment enfin
êtes-vous converti je devrais dire
converti y eu point s à l'écriture
inclusive l'écriture censé rétablir la
parité hommes femmes
cette écriture gagnent du terrain mais
pas sûr qu'elle fasse l'unanimité autour
de cette table on va en débattre avec
vous captez avec vous tous qui nous
suivaient sur lefigaro.fr et sur
facebook
merci d'être avec nous bonjour caroline
michel jeune journaliste à l'ope à l'ops
chef adjoint du service enquêtes vous
signez cette semaine une enquête qui
s'intitule glyphosate le poison est dans
le prêt révélations sur un scandale
sanitaire
absolument bonjour christophe devaux pts
historien professeur à sciences po
membre du conseil scientifique de la
fondapol fond d'appels qui publie où va
la démocratie
charles beigbeder bonjour hommes
d'affaires un politique conseiller
d'arrondissement dans le 8ème à paris
vous avez fondé avec l'ancien ministre
charles millon un think tank qui
s'appelle désormais l'avant garde et
vous êtes également co actionnaire du
magazine l'incorrect l'an dernier vous
avez écrit publié charnellement de
france au désir aux éditions pierre
guillaume de route
bonjour et pour compléter avec brio ce
plateau alexis brézet directeur des
rédactions du figaro georges ralli xi
doc la phrase prononcée par le président
de la république hier en corrèze a suffi
pour mettre le feu aux poudres
on les écoute avec attention il faut
tendre l'oreille
et on en parle plus elle sait lire
mais certains au lieu de le bordel ils
feraient mieux d'aller regarder il y en
a qui ont des qualités mais je sais bien
mais c'est comment dire non mais on ne
règle pas le problème d'une manière
branchée et lexis et du parler vrai ou
un dérapage
la nano ne sont pas exclusifs il
il est en visite dans une entreprise qui
gsm on lui montre tout un tas de de
perspectives d'emploi etc
par ailleurs à l'extérieur de cette
entreprise il ya des manifestants qui
sont pas cons tendre et est donc vous
voyez en les perspectives d'emploi et 10
au lieu de [ __ ] le bordel je l'adoré
chercher des emplois donc ils le pensent
donc de ce point de vue il ne dérape pas
dans un sens qui ne va pas au delà de
ski de ce qu'ils pensent ni absolument
ce qu'ils pensent sur le fond pas dire
que je trouve ça absolument choquant
c'est d'ailleurs amusant il ya une
espèce d'une immunité médiatique contre
ces mots là on a posé la question sur le
site du figaro vous en parlerai
peut-être je suis allé voir juste avoir
la démission il ya une cinquantaine de
milliers de votants il ya 60 ans
responsable des gens qui sont choqués
donc ça veut dire que entre le
l'unanimité médiatique contre cette
phrase est la réalité en tout cas des
internautes du figaro qui serait enfin
qui sont comme 20 millions par mois donc
ça doit ressembler comme un tout petit
peu au pays il ya une vraie est une
vraie différence donc sur le fond moi ça
me paraît pas absolument choquant après
on va en parler est ce qui politiquement
c'est une importance discute beaucoup
n'ont certainement pas c'est même un
vrai problème parce qu'il ya
actuellement en france près de 400 mille
offres d'emploi non pourvues et en même
temps donc trois millions et demi de
chômeurs et même beaucoup plus si on
prend toutes les catégories donc c'est
un vrai scandale c'est passé c'est une
horreur après c'est vrai ce que est ce
que le président américain doit
s'exprimer comme ça moi ça ne gène pas
forcément en plus il s était un aparté
donc ça aurait pas dû être rendu public
après tout soit que c'est senna boillon
qui a bien un qui disait bien de talent
que c'était de la merde dans un bas de
soie tout nous on pourrait citer aussi
nos grands rois et nos présidents plus
récents qui avaient parfois d'une façon
assez crue de parler on va arrêter de
faire les indignés à chaque fois que
quelqu'un mots un petit peu
familier d'utiliser par par le chef de
l'état oui si on doit aller un petit peu
plus loin pourquoi la presse ou les
commentateurs s'arrête sur ce mot c'est
parce que ça renvoie une polémique qui
est celle de la semaine dernière est ce
que manuel maquereau et le président des
riches tout simplement sur le fond
bordel pas bordel ça n'a strictement
aucune importance
la vraie question c'est est ce qu'il est
le président du riz des riches
et est-ce qu'il a un mépris de classe
pour les pauvres c'est appeler un chat
un chat c'est ce à quoi renvoie les mots
fainéants bordel et c'est moi pour ma
part je crois pas que ce soit mépris de
classe de la part d' emmanuel macron je
suis assez persuadé 2 depuis longtemps
que c'est potentiellement un mépris pour
tout ce qui n'est pas lui c'est à dire
qu'il a un certain nombre de critères
qui correspond à la politique qu'il mène
qui s'adresse à des gens jeunes mobiles
qui ont envie de se former curieux etc
on voit bien que la structure en tout
cas ce qu'il avait annoncé pendant sa
campagne correspond à ce profil et tout
ce qui n'est pas ça eh ben ça fout le
bordel
voilà c'est comme ça que j'analyse la
chose du christ vous êtes d'accord sur
cette quatrième position j'avais dit je
suis d'accord avec les trois autres mais
je pense que d'abord promis la prochaine
georges est par des faits il ya une
partie à mon avis presque piège dans la
mesure où je suis pas certain qu'il
était tout à fait conscient d'être
enregistrés mais enfin il s'en est
aperçu on voit le village personne
ils le voient je dirais justement une
fois qu'il l'a dit mais la question
n'est pas là la question c'est que je
pense en effet comme elle explose et que
la grande majorité des français sont
d'accord avec cette phrase les connais
pas eu d'autres situations à la hollande
où un président ne devrais pas dire ça
parce qu'un président disait à des
journalistes le contraire de ce qu'il
disait en public sur la justice sur
l'entreprise et ses sacs la grande
différence alors que la mgel macron dit
le fond de sa pensée et qui n'est pas
qui édite façon plus brutal que ce qu'il
dit en public mais quand il dit je veux
réactive et l'emploi c'est finalement
est ce que disaient aussi charleville
est très juste l'art cela dit j'ai de la
question du président des riches est
peut-être un petit peu différente et je
crois que justement on essaye ceux qui
sont contre bakr on essaye de
d'assimiler d'amalgamé la question du sf
et la question or il est très précis
puisqu'il dit certains certains disent
pas les ouvriers du parler vrai on va
juste écouter laurent bigorgne le
directeur de l'institut montaigne qui
était interrogé par marie laëtitia
bonavita c'était avant l'incident d'hier
mais vous allez voir il répond à la
question ce qu'on a qualifié de dérapage
a été extrêmement bien perçue par les
français
le seul accroc le mot fainéants non le
seul accroc sondagier est venu vous
rappeler aussi altercation sur le tee
shirt et le costard oui mais sinon tout
j'avais dire mes sorties verbales ou les
saillies verbales de celui qui est
ministre devenant candidats ont plutôt
été bien perçu
j'ai envie de l'analyse est un peu comme
si les gens disent aimer il ya un parler
vrai qui nous manque aujourd'hui et on a
le sentiment que macron par n'oserait je
leur donne tout de suite la parole mais
également les commentaires de nos
internautes avec marc laurent qui nous
disent ça peut arriver à n'importe qui
c'est humain et pourtant je n'ai pas
voté pour lui et lecteurs de de gaulle
c'est son nom nous dit c'est un dérapage
verbal représentatif de sa double
personnalité roselyne lévis ce n'est pas
mon cas de mon candidat mais je ne suis
pas choqué et richard c'est le président
des riches des ultra riches ils
dénigrent le peuple français et classe
ouvrière oui il ya le problème de ce
qu'il a dit il ya le problème de l'effet
de ce qu'il a dit et c'est vrai que
politiquement on a beaucoup c'est quand
même pas formidable
cet état là parce que c'est ce que dit
celui qui fait la ligue aurait un
problème c'est quand même pas la
première fois il l'a une habitude
récidive et ça va quand même toujours un
peu dans l'âme sentir que c'est une
parole de vérité qui constitue toujours
à dire que assemble de gens ne font pas
ce qu'il faut et ses quelques jours une
parole qui va du haut vers le bas qui
d'une parole
je n'ai pas forcément mais présente mais
en tout cas qu'ils condamnent qui est
qui dit bon c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut faire il ya eu la sphère des
illettrés dans l'histoire de gad
rappelez vous c'était en 2014
il ya eu en 2015 les français doivent de
tous devenir milliardaire c'est très
sympathique près tout pourquoi mais il
ya des gens qui disent bon il est bien
gentil mais moi je ne peux pas je
n'arrive pas en 2016 le costard tac
apple [ __ ] il vaut mieux travailler
pour que pour te payer c'est vrai aussi
mais c'est bon il ya eu cascades autres
les gares les fainéants les gars on
croit que des gens qui ne sont rien se
rend donc si on met boutoute bout à bout
toutes ces petites phrases ça dessine
comme un paysage psychologique qui même
si phrase après phrase semble de gens
disent oui la région ont dit ce qu'ils
pensent qu'ils créent une image de deux
distances de supériorité je suis parfois
que ça du mépris de classe
il ya sûrement un côté de technocratique
moi je sais ce qu'il faut faire c'est
tellement mais c'est tellement simple il
a qu'à le faire il ya des emplois non
pourvus mais allez-y les ans pas non
plus ça c'est quand même facile à dire
quand on est du bon côté ce que nous
sommes les uns et les autres pour les
gens qui perçoivent ça une partie bas
ils le sentent mal c'est par exemple
l'arrogance c'est ce que dénonce
christian jacob président du groupe plr
à l'assemblée nationale qu'on va écouter
évidemment il n'est pas d'accord avec
aurore bergé qui elle député la
république en marche minimes c'est de
l'arrogance
tout cela il fait à dessein c'est pas il
n'est pas pris part une perche par
hasard à vous le niveau long terme le
sait parfaitement
comme les déclarations inhabituelles
précédente et
c'est de l'arrogance et on a un
président qui ne supporte pas la moindre
contestation
et il a dit des choses est encore plus
violente 50 il dit que lorsqu'il est
dans une gare il y a ceux qui ont tous
réussi ceux qui ne sont rien ceux qui ne
sont rien mais quelle violence et pas
ceux qui n'ont pas réussi ce qui ne sont
rien il dit absolument pas et désigne
personne par par cette expression
encore une fois ce qui est important
c'est comme sur la foule
chacun doit prendre ses responsabilités
le président de la république a pris ses
responsabilités sur voir le cool on a
des solutions on a des repreneurs on a
des entreprises en ce moment qui
surviennent dans ce pays qui créent de
l'emploi
et c'est ça qu'il faut accompagner c'est
ça notre job mais c'est la
responsabilité de chacun que
d'accompagner la création d'emplois dans
ce pays sur l'habilité on a entendu
christian jacob mais en même temps les
républicains n'ont pas été tous à réagir
tous azimuts sur cette question parce
qu'ils sont un peu gênés aux entournures
finalement on l'apprend cerveau aussi
que sur le fond il a raison mais je
pense pas que ça a été fait avec
arrogance mais je ne crois pas aux
revanches peut-être que christian jacob
a raison sur le fait que ça a été fait à
dessein parce que et c'est paris sur les
la phrase les faits n'ayant pas ce que
ça a été fait les fainéants il le dit la
veille de la grande manif des syndicale
donc comme si ils avaient envie que
presque de d'aider ces mouvements
sociaux a réussi à mobiliser un peu plus
et puis ensuite de les battre parce qu'à
ce moment là sur ce congrès et
pourraient avoir plus les mains libres
pour toujours cette stratégie qu'on lui
attribue de vouloir faire de mélenchon
son meilleur adversaire
moi j'en arrive à la stratégie proposée
c'est trop moi je crois pas ça me faire
beaucoup dit le programme comprend la
vie c'est pas comme ça ils disent qu'ils
peuvent ils le portent à 120 jours
disent oui il a raison de le penser mais
à l'arrivée ça dessine un paysage qui
quoi qu'on puisse dire n'est quand même
pas formidable les sondages ne sont pas
bons il faut bien qu'ils aient une
raison aussi fait que baisser c'est sans
doute en partie sa politique qui déçoit
une partie de son électorat il faut bien
voir que macro ont été lus en grande
partie par des gens de gauche qui sont
des gens du
directeur ex socialiste qui voulait pas
de amont une partie électeurs de droite
qui au dernier moment mais les tendances
sont restés derrière françois fillon
donc beaucoup de ses lecteurs sont des
gens de gauche qui légitimement 10
ben c'est pas notre politique et c'est
vrai que c'est en mêler de la politique
de macron sur 1 sur le papier on peut
pas dire que soit une politique
aujourd'hui que extraordinairement de
gauche donc il ya ça évidemment et donc
on le voit dans les sondages
et puis là sans doute aussi une partie
de ce comportement et les deux se
cumulent puisque c'est aussi une
lectorat de gauche qui peut se sentir
humilié vexé brutalisé par ce genre de
propos qu'on a les mêmes sources alexis
parce que il ya le baromètre du figaro
magazine qui effectivement montre une
de nouveau une chute de la popularité de
manuel macron qui atteint la même cote
de confiance de celle de françois
hollande à la même période avec et saab
est fort dans les catégories de gauche
avec douceur et les catégories
populaires pas mal au discours politique
et que je trouve un peu plus d'essence
et la réaction du camp de macron c'est à
dire que je trouve que la défense n'est
pas très très bien organisé ces
substitutions minimisation quand vous
avez très bien dit alors que je crois
qu'il pourrait assez aisément assumer de
façon pédagogique dans un autre langage
utilisé l'argument de charles beigbeder
il ya quatre cent mille emplois et en
l'occurrence la vis à une entreprise
juste à côté qui était dans ce cas là
qui ne sont pas pourvus et là peut-être
qu'un jour il faudra que le président
présidentielle mans reviennent sur ce
thème mais avec un langage évidemment
beaucoup plus efficace beaucoup plus
tenue et qu'ils assument
en effet des vérités d'évidence qui sont
à mon avis partagé par une majorité de
français encore une fois par une échelle
ça vous fait réagir ses emplois qui ne
sont pas pourvus non j'ai la solution
est plutôt sur la posture dans la
communication emmanuel macron dans ces
moments là lui qui est un homme de
contrôle me fait penser enfin je le
trouve une filiation avec nicolas
sarkozy
alors on n'est pas aux castors casse toi
pauvre con mais il ya quelque chose du
chef viril qui s'impose dans sa manière
de parler de dire ils n'ont qu'à quelque
chose un petit peu qui roule des
mécaniques que je trouve très en droite
ligne avec une communication viril qu'on
a eus sous nicolas sarkozy et qui
n'avait rien à voir avec la façon dont
françois hollande exerçait le pouvoir
communication la virile match ou non
mais à ton choix entre ces deux postures
dans une france qui aime le chef de
d'incarner cette sorte de virilité
arrêtons d'empêcher les hommes des
dribbles s'assainir mal ce disque
excusez moi ça n'est pas moi je n'ai pas
à juger c'est vous qui voyez 1h10
émotions ça me gêne j'ai pas dit que ça
me gênait j'ai dit que je trouvais qu'il
y avait une filiation dans la manière de
se positionner de travail en français
qui n'était pas éloignée de celle de
nicolas sarkozy
mais ce qui avait fait le jeu n'oublions
pas ne réécrira pas l'histoire ce qui
avait fait le succès nicolas sarkozy en
2007 se parler vrai et là il faudra être
câblées ou la brèche la brèche soit
définitivement fait dans le mur du
politiquement correct c'est top c'est
tout à fait vrai faux oui c'est vrai
qu'un temps le pape le parler vrai de
ces sarkozy essaie d'en parler populaire
il se mettait du côté où doit soit
pourquoi il était quand même dans ce par
les belges et même les élites les gens
bien d'installer qui ne vont pas comme
ça qu'on traîne non mais les classes
populaires se sentait plus tôt mais
voilà il ressemblait là c'est un peu le
contraire et c'est le cas dans os qui
disent qu'il faut faire en gardant bas
donc oui dans l'expression mais non dans
l'endroit au monde où on parle mais il
n'ya pas aussi une langage politique qui
se finalement kim on n'a plus beaucoup
de tenue il y avait un député la france
a soumis ce matin qui était interrogé
sur rtl qui réagissait aux propos d'
emmanuel macron et qui lui disait sur un
autre sujet darmanin c'est un bois très
féministe de c'est un bourrin très peu
mais l'on met dans des propos volet
enfin c'est à la limite gênant parce que
si un président doit se contrôler en
permanence ou moi tous les jours on dit
bordel donc on n'est pas dans un oui
c'est comme ça c'est la tête le total de
cas des caméras partout des smartphones
par tous et toutes bon on peut dire que
c'est bien que c'est à dire peu importe
on n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui un dirigeant
politique et un plaisir d'un public doit
se contrôler tout c'est effectivement
pas des propos on peut pas parler de
propos voler encore une fois la can
la perche demi mot hélas il y avait là
le décor et le et le porte parole de
manuel macron a rendu sa public
immédiatement donc on passe au sujet des
facs
est ce un nouveau prolétariat pour jean
luc mélenchon en tout cas il veut or un
rôle et les étudiants derrière lui faut
effectivement d'avoir fait descendre des
centaines de milliers de salariés dans
la rue lafrance insoumise espère
désormais soulever les facs un tract
intitulé 10 raisons de se mobiliser
contre la bande à macron et distribué
dès aujourd'hui massivement dans les
universités et une pétition est aussi
mise en ligne il peut réussir jean luc
mélenchon christophe de boxe dans cet
appel vous qui êtes familier des
universités ça me paraît plus je dirais
plus plus important peut-être que que la
gaffe on va dire des macros je pense que
là il ya une vraie question politique et
l'état de la jeunesse française n'est
pas brillantissime notamment dans les
universités quand vous parlez
prolétariat les universités je dis bien
et où ça allait très bien quelle
distinction en france entre les
universités et les grandes écoles et au
sein des universités entre et au sein
même de chaque université entre les
filières il y avait une clientèle
potentielle
pour lui d'ailleurs qui a en partie
quand même voter pour lui il a une
personne un fort électorat jeune c'est
pas vrai c'est pas bête un politiquement
c'est assez dangereux
il ya eu vous savez la réduction des apl
sujets de mécontentement sont mais voilà
en face des apl cette voie vers citées
exactement il faudrait un effet je serai
la place du gouvernement je ferai
attention à ce lait qui bout et qui
pourraient déborder
attention danger quelle histoire c'est
pas nouveau
enfin on a connu l'époque où dre
cambadélis farine f
l'unef dessin contre chirac activé par
mitterrand depuis l'époque où une
ramdane mais delphine batho alors je
sais activé par mitterrand de 50 euros
car et puis il y en a eu tellement
tellement tellement l'idée que d'élite
la gauche alors au tour face à la gauche
du ps est aujourd'hui à plus de ps et on
sent bien qu'au fond mélenchon veut vous
pouvez être ça je prends les étudiants
pour essayer de les monter contre le
gouvernement
c'est un bon ça peut dans une mesure
marché généralement ça marche quand ce
sont des sujets qui concernent des
étudiants donc déjà pour première chose
c'est que s'il en est a pas ses
auditeurs 6 le reste n'a pas marché
c'est à dire que le flat les ouvriers
sont pas descendus dans la rue les
fonctionnaires on va voir mais enfin bon
de toute façon donc maintenant on essaie
les étudiants mais les étudiants les
ordonnances les retraites la formation
on peut dire que ça les concerne par
raccroc mais tant que les appels en ce
sens y ait la paix elle vient d appel
voilà et puis il ya la fête
enfin est-ce que les étudiants même
s'ils sont pas contents considère comme
un scandale absolu qu'on leur retire 5
euros pas à tous par mois je ne suis pas
sûr est ce que ça vous parce que la
mairie de voir aprilia qui accéléra
sélection c'est l'exaltation d'être
aidés qu'ils ont donc des prêts fictifs
sont absolument nécessaires vitesses
celle là elle est difficile il faudra le
faire mais peut-être qu'il faut pas tout
faire en même temps
d'ailleurs on voit que blanc caire on
parle peu en ce moment blanc caire
effectivement il n'a pas du tout abordé
ce sujet dans les annonces qu'il a
faites depuis la rentrée la fille c'est
pas son sujet non plus facile n'est pas
ministre l'enseignement supérieur mais
la ficelle sur laquelle ti jean luc
mélenchon il est un peu grosse et
vieille comme la mouche ça on vient de
le rappeler en effet il n'a pas réussi à
faire la jonction avec les syndicats
dans la rue qu'il espérait il se dit moi
je vais faire une insurrection dans la
rue quelle est la population la plus
abrupte yves potentiellement c'est les
étudiants ils sont pas contents par leur
part les apl ils sont surtout pas
content par le fonctionnement de
l'admission post bac donc je vais les
chercher
la jeunesse est en déshérence amener
plus structurée par le mouvement des
jeunes socialistes comme elle l'a été
beaucoup de jeunes ont voté pour
mélenchon donc je dirais que le calcul
est assez transparent pas bête
est ce que est ce que ça va marcher
c'est difficile à dire je n'entrais une
chose pour faire écho à ce que vous
venez de dire c'est qu'on n'a pas
entendu pas très bien entendu le
gouvernement ni macron pendant la
campagne sur la jeunesse
ils nous ont dit qu'ils préparaient un
plan dont j'ai déjà oublié le nom sur la
vie étudiante mais on ne sait pas de
quoi de qui
deux camps donc je pense que en effet
c'est un sujet qu'il ne faut pas
négliger pour le gouvernement et qui
pour l'instant est un peu passé au
travers des mailles du filet on le
rappeler tout al heure trente pour cent
des électeurs de mélenchon entre 18 et
24 ans va plus non pardon c'est 30 % des
jeunes ont voté pour mélenchon c'est la
droite elle a perdu l'électorat jeune
ah bah oui les républicains c'était
affligeant je crois qu'ils aient une
malheureuse ans filles ont dû faire 7 %
donc aussi bien sûr il faudra la
bataille avant profond nationale et donc
je comprends que mélenchon la france
insoumise essaye d'aller sur ce public
puisqu'ils ont perdu le prolétariat
enfin les classes populaires qui sont
soit dans l'abstention soit au front
national et donc il ya ce public
c'est d'ailleurs très étonnant est
préoccupante parce que il défend des
idées qui sont quand même que j'estime
folle et les jeunes ne faudra peut-être
leur rappeler ce que le xxème siècle a
produit ce que les totalitarismes
d'extrême gauche en produits comme le
nombre de victimes
là il ya peut-être un pamphlet à écrire
pour parce que c'est ahurissant que 30%
des jeunes soient séduits par cette
thèse moi je trouve ça il retrouve pas
d'alternative ça me paraît tout sauf
lloris ans mais il ne trouve pas dans
l'éternel ce qui correspondrait que
mélenchon il a fait une bonne campagne
on va pas en faire tout le majeur et
essentiel mais il avait été assez
innovant en termes de communication clés
il a quelques leaders autour de lui qui
sont assez bons comme ce qu'en disent
ils à un substrat idéologique qu'il faut
pas négliger dans la jeunesse c'est
encore une fois il suffit d'une
étincelle je crois je parlais des appels
d'autres choses mais n'oubliez pas quand
même que lente les thèmes comme l'anti
racisme justice la justice sociale eux
l'anticapitalisme forcené un d'une
grande part de la jeunesse française
je dirais même nanti économie samedi des
accords quand on a fait des études sur
les connaissances économiques de notre
vie nos jeunes c'est pas extraordinaire
donc tout cela peut conduire il ya un
substrat qui on l'a eu d'assez favorable
vous mettez l'état celle et vous avez le
talent d'un meneur
d'agitation comme mélenchon vous pouvez
avoir quelque chose du tout mais moi je
suis historien je suis pas prophète de
lui dès ses jeunes
gilles à 7,7 à tous si on peut dire on a
juste avant de donner la parole
je donne la liste je l'interromps juste
pour parce qu'on a des internautes qui
reste beaucoup sur ce sujet samir el
houari le sujet de ce jeune sans doute
le samir el houari le sujet des apl est
cruciale pour le monde étudiant caroline
qui nous disent 5 euros c'est énorme
quand on est déjà en galère
mais au delà c'est surtout la symbolique
déjà que les étudiants du mal à joindre
les deux bouts notamment à paris c'est
un signe qu'on se soucie à peine de nous
oui ce sera de toute manière un souci
tant que c'est m enfin soucis ou un
potentiel ça ne dépend comment on peut
le voir mais tant que ces thèmes de
convient d'évoquer de justice sociale ne
sont pas récupérés par une gauche
modérée qui n'existe plus donc tant que
l'espace c'est pas parce que le parti
socialiste a disparu temporairement ou
pas que ses idées ce qu'il portait et
les gens qui avaient envie d'y croire on
disparu dont de toute manière dans cet
espace qui laissé béant pour l'instant
il y a des gens à draguer j'ai envie de
dire et chacun va essayer chacun à son
tour de voir si si ça prend
monsieur mélenchon s'y emploie mélenchon
était plutôt en phase de recentrage
précisément puisqu'il a vu sa taille
aimerait façon dont six ont conduit par
face à edouard philippe l'autre soir la
télévision c'est pas le leader
bolchévique n'est pas tout le boulot de
feu mais se dit bon crepax rica toit
lors du contraire bon je garde mes mains
mon ancrage à gauche s'était notamment
ces jeunes là mais je vais essayer
d'élargir à jouer l'apple app le dc10
existe plus macro prend pas le terrain
je vais essayer d'aller prendre c'est
logique qu'ils tentent le coup à un
mollet mais ce qu'ils gagnent d'un côté
il va le père de l'autre pas pour
l'instant
pour l'instant non le tout là tout le
jeu c2d large d'élargir sa base
de proche en proche là où c'est plus et
maquereau qui lui dans une logique
presque de substitution des lecteurs ça
c'est comme toujours périlleux j'ajoute
que dans l'électorat étudiants et ses
étudiants des enseignants
donc mes collègues et les idées de
mélenchon se porte aussi très bien chez
les enseignants du secondaire mais aussi
chez beaucoup d'universitaires donc il y
aura je dire ils ne seront pas contredit
sur sa ligne par les professeurs surtout
les professeurs de sciences économiques
surtout les prestations des sciences
économiques et sociales c'est son nom
est oui donc et les collègues historiens
d'accord donc parce que justement je ne
suis pas sûr qu'ils en savent beaucoup
sur le totalitarisme soviétique du 20ème
siècle
donc je pense que non veillon jeu réel
ou arnaud bouchon d'un verré au grain
les filles ont d'abord été élève
on y revient une seconde le rapport de
la cour des comptes au vitriol sur
l'éducation nationale dont on a fait
mouche est du figaro ce matin justement
disait jean michel blanquer on ne
s'attaque pas aux vrais réformes
il va il va s'y mettre un jour vous êtes
du maire juste avait il annoncé beaucoup
de choses sur le plan du recrutement des
professeurs de la rémunération de leur
évaluation de l'ats je suis en l'air
toutes les raisons de najat
vallaud-belkacem déjà donc on va dire
qu'il n'a rien fait cette cellule a mis
en l'air la réforme des collèges et son
peuple
est-ce que ça a vraiment c'est le
mammouth elle qu'on leur accorde à sa
sera pas mince ça se fera pas en un jour
il ya mille choses à faire il a annoncé
cette affaire d'université avec la cnac
faire des prérequis qui en fait est un
mot pudique pour parler de sélection
extrêmement explosif est extrêmement me
semble-t-il extrêmement nécessaire
il a quand même mis pas mal de cheveux
de choses à dire sur l'addition des
trois arrivées en masse à faire des
choses
il a repris la main sur la fabrication
des programmes au point que l'usso le
patron de la ceni ce n'est non peu là
pour le coup lui aussi supérieur des
programmes 12 ans a rien fait s'est
passé le les enseignants le coeur du
sujet quand même aussi je changerais
vraiment d'accord avec ses visions pour
moi le coeur du problème c'est
l'administration de l'enseignement c'est
pas les enseignants enfin moi qui des
enfants qui suis au contact avec
les profs depuis des années je peux vous
dire que ces profs ont une capacité de
résilience qu'il fait mon admiration à
chaque rentrée il nous explique que
telles réformes telles réformes telles
réformes avec conviction qu'ils vont
essayer de faire ce qu'il faut enfin
faut voir je leur fait voir si ces
pauvres étudiants face à une hiérarchie
qui ne fait rien pour eux donc vraiment
je voudrais qu'on fasse la différence
entre il ya des brebis galeuses comme
partout et dans tous les métiers dans la
presse aussi y en a mais entre des gens
qui sont au contact du terrain et qui
pour beaucoup afin - de ce que je
renvoie se donnent vraiment de la peine
pour un contexte on est toujours en
train de le reprocher y compris la pluie
les jours de pluie et une administration
qui ne m'est vraiment pas à leur écoute
je crois qu'il faut séparer les deux
sujets enfin c'est plus une organisation
qu'une administration ca clair c'est
ainsi 5000 ex amant figé où il n'y a
aucun qui soit aucune marche de magna
aucune liberté et où tout est contraint
y compris d'ailleurs dans l'enseignement
privé sous contrat que démontrer cour
des comptes notamment la gestion par les
syndicats de ça donc ça c'est comme les
enseignants c'est dans l'administration
c'est un système qui est verrouillé
sclérosé entre les mains des syndicats
mes pensées ou le mérite le travail ne
compte pour rien où seul compte l'ancien
d'ancienneté les acomptes en 50 syndical
il ya pas deux on parle de
l'administration mais les proviseurs ça
ce sont des enseignants eux mêmes ils
n'ont qu'un pouvoir ils n'ont pas le
choix de ce cher il peut même pas
vraiment choisi mon errance les
enseignants et on ne peut pas les virer
ça c'est sûr donc c'est aussi c'est
interdit par la loi pécresse n'était pas
les eaux il n'a pas été dans l'est dans
le secondaire ni dans le primaire c'est
moi je crois que justement la proche de
blanc caire est fondamental il faut
surtout pas prononcer le mot réforme
les gens n'en peuvent plus de réformes
qu'il avait très bien dit et il suffit
de mettre une réforme et là vous avez
mélenchon est qui et qui si je dis
retrouvera un os à ronger
non il faut justement être pragmatique
faire des expériences autant que
possible développer
les bonnes pratiques comme on dit est
épuisée et puis attendre la contagion
est ensuite enregistrée par le contrat
par la loi on verra bien je vois qu'il a
une approche extrêmement intelligente
dans un milieu qui est traumatisé par
les réformes
d'autre part pour parler de mes
collègues et une chirurgie mais pas du
corporatisme
il a beaucoup plus de gens prêts à
l'écouter qu'on ne croit moi je vois
dans l'opinion publique
enseignante il y à une lassitude
vis-à-vis du système égalitariste
justement et surtout vis à vis des
salaires qui sont quand même mais nabeul
en europe contre quand je lui passais
devant le savoir et par rapport à nos
collègues allemands anglais et caetera
et moi je vois beaucoup de dents de
d'enseignants notamment qu'ils étaient
des électeurs du parti socialiste et qui
sont par ces schémas kron parce qu'eux
mêmes certains chez fillon
j'ose le dire qu'ils ont parce que
justement il attendait une
revalorisation de leurs conditions et ça
on peut le faire sans faire des lois etc
on peut on peut le déverrouiller et je
pense que ce sera gérable anker fera
autre élément à porter à l'actif de
blogueurs la sphère des méthodes de
lecture c'est tout à fait mal hein la
façon nos différents goûts évoluent en
méthode syllabique les vieilles méthodes
la méthode bouger mais dis pas ça dit
pas je reviens avant parce qu'avant ça a
marché mieux il dit la main des roses
neurosciences nous ont fait découvrir
que c'était mieux que le semis globale
elle tournait à ben oui c'est moi
c'était assez malin il faire cela dit de
robien l'avait déjà dit la
technostructure à fait le contraire ce
qu'ils disent un ministre qui a émergé
dans une immense et bien bloqués c'est
la réussite de la rentrée alors c'est un
professeur enfin on l'a un peu oublié
dominique strauss kahn lui dit
aujourd'hui qu'il ya une différence
entre les valeurs de droite et les
valeurs de gauche il vous dit avec force
était mardi soir lors d'un hommage à
l'ancienne ministre nicole bricq hommage
auquel assistaient françois hollande et
emmanuel macron vous allez découvrir à
l'écran les extraits de ce discours de
dominique strauss kahn
il dit notamment les deux donc les
valeurs de droite et de gauche sont
nécessaires à l'équilibré de la société
mais leurs oppositions dialectique vivra
tant que vivra la démocratie il est mêlé
ce n'est pas les confondre
c'est un tacle à
emmanuel macron de la part de dominique
strauss kahn oui oui c'est le va dire
ben il a finalement ils étaient sûrs
même créé au maquereau cemac roncq a
décroché la timbale donc il est jaloux
je suis pas sûr que ce soit que ça
d'abord je pense comme le pense vraiment
et que par ailleurs il l'est beaucoup
plus à gauche comme accro faut pas
oublier que dominique srauss kahn tout
moderne qu'il soit libéré les pâtes
alimentaires
c'est l'homme qui a inventé les 35
heures c'est pas martine aubry qui a
inventé les 35 heures donc strauss kahn
c'est un vrai politique il est dans le
sérail du parti sioniste depuis des
années des années côté requis à la
gauche qu'à la droite
il est d'une gauche social-libérale plus
moderne plus réformatrice mais n'empêche
qu'il est de gauche
macron la question se pose vraiment
c'est normal et donc ça désoriente les
gens de gauche et les gens de droite
quant à l'analyse de fond de 2 france 4
qui vous c'est à dire la droite la
droite et la gauche deux sont là pour
l'éternité
enfin c'est une vraie discussion moi ça
me suis pas en désaccord avec ça la
question est de savoir s'il n'y a pas
des périodes où les repères se
brouillent et se recompose ensuite et
c'est justement ce que fait ma combat il
sait exactement je vais maintenant parce
qu'il y avait une ambiguïté il y avait à
droite et au centre des personnes qu'ils
ont finalement très progressiste et qui
sont beaucoup plus proches de la gauche
que leurs collègues du reste de la
droite
pas de jalousie de la part de nos
histoires comme moi je trouve l'ensemble
extrêmement indécent allait s'en faut
d'abord rappeler que c'était
l'enterrement d'une ministre ex ministre
est mort tragiquement mais que deux
anciens présidents fin deux anciens
représentants dirigeants de la gauche
sont venus quelque part prononcé
l'homélie de la gauche socialiste et
nous expliquer pourquoi il avait raison
quand même enfin bon je trouve
l'ensemble me met d'autant plus mal à
l'aise que le noyau la structuration de
base
2 en marche au départ ce sont des
strauss kahniens
quand vous allez dans les comités locaux
de en marche où vous voyez des gens
disent part à des primes aux militants
des gens de qualité chez ségolène royal
et tout ça et que vous leur demandez
mais au début comment vous avez
fonctionne et on vous dira mais c'est
les gens de chez strauss kahn il avait
l'habitude
donc le côté moi j'avais raison mais il
fallait écouter mais quand même je suis
plus malin ça me met assez mal à l'aise
est ce que on est une fois encore dans
le commentaire de l'action politique
ce qui a été un peu la maladie de la
gauche est dans l'idéologie
la vérité c est ce que se dit dominique
strauss kahn correspond à la période
actuelle nous il me semble que non on
verra plus tard
mais venir faire un discours un petit
peu idéologues sur la droite la gauche
et c'est au moment où les strauss
kahniens sont en partie au pouvoir me
paraît un peu étrange
il a enterré la gauche aussi de me
strauss kahn c'était le compte rendu
qu'en faisait la journaliste de l'oignon
les commentaires sur son propre
enterrement parce que je ne pense pas
que ça le rendent particulièrement
populaire
je sens quand même la blessure des
gaules et là il ya aussi des images qui
tue le jour où on accuse le président de
la république de mépriser le peuple et
c'est à ce colloque on voit on voit
dominique strauss kahn partir en
limousine avec chauffeur et après nous
envoyer des valeurs de la gauche je
parle encore une fois du visuel c'est je
pense qu'il y assez mal placé notamment
vis-à-vis des catégories populaires pour
donner des leçons
je dirais de d'amour des cartes des
classes populaires donc des valeurs de
gauche et en plus franchement moi j'ai
relu 10 fois cette phrase on parle de la
pensée complexe du président mais reste
l'excusé du rire bien compris moi je
vais car lease moi même pas très bien
comprendre la pensée complexe de
dominique strauss kahn entre la
dialectique n'équilibre la vie ensemble
à la limite
emmanuel macron aurait pu dire ça aussi
en fait dans la campagne où l'ag parle
d'eux est un droit inné à dire je suis
bien sûr donc je crois que ça va
disparaître très vite ça va être très
vite emporté dans ma nature lancé
tétreault parce que quand mutuel le
rappeler benjamin griveaux ismaël et mes
liens bien comme ça vienne de chine il
ya une influence réelle travaux sur jean
reno je peux pas vous dire non moi je
voulais juste dire c'est que sur le fond
parce que bon après je suis d'accord
avec vous ce n'était peut-être pas le
lieu pour faire un tel discours
mais sur le fond il a quand même raison
dsk il ya une droite et une gauche c'est
pas pareil là et d'ailleurs ce que
macron a fait à opérer ça va peut-être
clarifier les choses la droite c'est
autre chose que je sais que ce sont ses
mots
la ligne 3 qui a existé comme l'un des
individus dans un espace commercial qui
essaient de vivre plus ou moins en
harmonie il ya ceux qui croient qu il ya
une nation il ya une histoire qui nous
structure ça c'est la droite et donc si
on revient à ça c'est une bonne chose
pour préciser ce que je voulais dire
finalement ce que je trouve indécent
c'est que dominique strauss kahn et
françois hollande sont venus nous dire
on met la gauche et je trouve que cette
gauche là ne fait preuve d'un manque
d'autocritique assez frappant puisque
c'est cette gauche là qui a perdu le
vote de l'électorat populaire et c'est
quand même ça au final moi qui m'a fait
ça ces choses et le débat théorique sur
la toile
oui parce que c'est depuis la révolution
française jusqu'à la fin des temps c'est
un vrai elle est là on peut en discuter
les clivages sont pas forcément la
tombola
voilà ce que ne sont pas fans peuvent
être orthogonaux sur certains sujets et
puis à l'indécence dire quand on voit au
lendemain de ce flic ça va mieux aussi
grâce à lui bon les moins nous en
tombent quand michel sapin a expliqué ce
qu'il fallait faire sur le chômage aux
habitants ça ne disqualifie pas le débat
sur la portée à cause de ces deux points
différents
le plan différent non non non mais on
est encore dans le commentaire c'est à
dire que ce sont des gens dominique
strauss kahn qui prétendait ne pas être
dans le commentaire
justement quand une thèse ou les dires
un peu silence pudique l'écriture
inclusive
est ce un nouveau délire féministe en
tout cas le masculin ne l'emportent pas
sur le féminin c'est l'avis des
promoteurs de cette écriture dit
inclusive écriture qui viserait à
rétablir la parité entre les hommes et
les femmes dans la langue française si
les noms et les adjectifs sont
systématiquement écrit au masculin et au
féminin on va en voir un exemple à
l'écran avec ce point médian dont on va
parler
une question pour vous tous c'est une
marotte délirantes ou c dans l'air du
temps x moi j'avais envie de lui dire
que oui si vous m'aviez fait venir en
tant que femme pour défendre féministes
ou chez pac quoi cette histoire s'est
c'est tragique mais en plus c'est tout
ça et développer il faut rappeler dans
un manuel pour les élèves de ce2 je suis
en vigueur mais qu'on laisse nos enfants
tranquilles quoi l'orthographe est déjà
suffisamment complexe pour qu'on ne
vienne pas l'heure alors ce sont les
rolling michel est en train de vous
couper l'herbe sous le pied à tous
je vais commencer le débat la langue
française n'est pas une langue neutre
contrairement à l'anglais oui la réponse
est oui
est-ce qu'elle marque est ce qu'elle
exprime le caractère dominant masculin
de notre société oui est ce qu'il
faudrait est ce que les femmes devrait
revendiquer des choses pour leurs
conditions oui absolument il est un
scandale qu'au xxième siècle les femmes
continuent à être dévalorisé payer moins
que les hommes et c est ce que le sujet
est très important oui chaque jour on a
des ddd exemple dans notre vie que la
place des femmes mais est très loin
d'être légalité de celle des hommes
coiffés madonna 20 cm c'est pas le lieu
c'est pas le lieu est alors qu'on me
démontre que le point inclusif qui n'est
même pas qu'on ne peut même pas exprimer
à l'oral va c'est 7 ce qui me gêne c'est
d'y enfin les bleus présidence et le
point milieu
le global mais sais-tu alors qu'au
milieu dont j'ai quand même appris je
vous précise que jusqu'à présent parce
que c'est aussi ça fait partie du débat
il les claviers azerty vous me sans
doute le prévoit mais jusqu'à présent si
vous vouliez par exemple alexis mettre
un point milieu au médian il faut
appuyer sur la touche alt et 0 183 sur
votre pavé numérique
pourquoi 0 5 0 883 sais pas je suis très
pragmatique
donc le point milieu c'est ce qu'il ya
entre metz et le poids qui n'est pas un
point final mairie culte triste mais qui
se place donc en début on s'est dit on
va faire des parentes c'est une escouade
est pas absolument sûr aller c'est à
dire à faire des parenthèses après tout
ça en allemagne mais non parce qu'une
parenthèse ça montre que c'est
secondaire soutien entre parenthèses
c'est pas bien alors prêt si on va faire
des dessins côté défendre c'est-à-dire
faire un slash mais le sache et une
opposition auteurs triste non les
agricultrices sont proposés aux rideaux
c'est pas parce que c'est un débat dans
le débat il ya eu quand même cette
féminisation des noms de métiers
qu'on a plus plus vous n'aurez qu'une
triste mais dire que parler des
agriculteurs est absolument scandaleux
mais les avocats les magistrats l'on
peut dire à l'avocat l'ambassadrice le
premier stade donc vous dites c'est
celui là si on rajoute un au final c'est
le tout et tout faisait ce chacune et
chacun sait un peu grotesque mais bon
allez je veux bien mais là où ça devient
de la purge olive puis city 2 c'est ce
truc qu'on met des points on coupe les
mots ça n'a absolument aucun sens mais
sa part que le manioc lattier c'est le
haut conseil à l'égalité creed énorme
surtout c'est la tornade à sciences po
fessée communiqué en langage inclusif
envoie ses émissions à ses étudiants des
mets langage accueilli il ya de plus en
plus à se répandre en plein
d'administration de partis politiques
même les républicains entendent en tant
que le medef dont vous êtes familier je
crois on m'a dit avait il y avait 1
un production du medef en écriture
accuse yves quelle tristesse non ça
c'est pathétique c'est grotesque
là ça fait penser ces néo féministes
nous font penser aux précieuses
ridicules alors que pendant ce temps les
vrais combats sont ailleurs c'est à dire
c'était sont dans nos banlieues
elles sont dans dans cette développement
d'un islam radical qui tente à
considérer que la femme est l'inférieur
de l'homme alors que c'est tout le
contraire de la civilisation française
pendant des siècles on a en a on a
justement donné toute sa belle place à
la femme d'où le nom de deux dames
d'ailleurs et c'est affligeant et ces
féministes de peur de se faire accuser
d'être islamophobe peut-être ne
s'intéresse pas aux vrais sujets qui
qu'est ce qu'on a sous les yeux vous me
donnez l'occasion de parler du figaro
magazine la prochaine parution qui
effectivement le sujet c'est
l'atmosphère enquête sur les agents
d'influencé de l'islam
mais pour revenir au sujet on va écouter
aussi emmanuel macron emmanuel macron
qui pas d'écriture inclusif mais quand
même un peu
je n'ai rien contre celles et ceux qui
portent des tee-shirts ou celles et ceux
qui pensent que vous ne rien faire que
celles et ceux qui avec cynisme il pense
que son avenir ailleurs que c'était ceux
qui sont aux extrêmes est venu
pays souffrent oui c'est ceux qui
commettent des actes terroristes dans
tous les domaines il faut la salle et se
faisait tous les hommes et les femmes
mais à jean nous a rejoints bonjour je
vous rejoins je ne sais pas bonjour mais
roanne alors sur les réseaux sociaux
cette écriture inclusive elle se décrit
comment alors c'est l'ironie qui domine
on a l'un des prix meuse qui est taquine
et qui nous dit l'écriture inclusif va
nous faire comprendre qu'on est dans un
état de droit at eux on a un gars y
berthe de l'hebdo les jours qui pensent
que twitter réfléchit depuis quelques
jours à l'augmentation des caractères de
140 à 280 caractère notamment pour ceux
qui sont fervents de la décision
inclusive
on a nos ennemis a lieu à de
l'hebdomadaire actualité juive qui a
imaginé un poème de la fontaine dans
l'écriture inclusive et qu'il ne
tarissant tweets par suicide et vous
alors internautes je vous invite à
mettre le replay de cette émission est
affaire pose sur le poème et essayer de
le dire c'est très compliqué et alexis
brézet et caroline michel on à henri
michel qui nous dit d'ici à 5 ans
l'écriture inclusif sera adoptée par la
presse et on distinguera les vieux
journaliste des jeunes par son usage
comme pour les anciens et nouveaux
francs ou d euros il y aura sûrement les
deux tronitruant dans les rédacs diront
trop saoulé avec ses pentes il est là
c'est à la note est il visionnaire non
mais où alors qu'on utilise dans notre
langage s'est-elle ce que je voulais
dire dans mon énervement d'adultes dans
les comics etc
oui pourquoi pas mais que la première
démarche
oui pourquoi pas mais que la croissance
soit d'aller même ça dans les manuels
pédagogiques de nos propres enfants de
ce2 ça me paraît
laissons-les son étrange débat puis je
vous dire quelque chose là dessus c'est
que en fait non ce ne sera pas adoptée
dans les cinq ans pour une entrée simple
c'est que on peut toujours aller plus
loin dans l'écriture inclusive plus si
vous voulez y aura toujours des débats
justement de précieuses ridicules je
prends l'exemple que j'ai bien connu
quand je travaille au quai d'orsay sur
madame l'ambassadrice et bien les femmes
qui était ambassadeur ne voulait pas
qu'on les appelle madame l'ambassadrice
parce que jusque-là on disait madame
l'ambassadrice pour la femme de
l'ambassadeur
donc c'est interminable donc on va avoir
bientôt des directrice pascale jusqu'à
présent avait des directrices moussa
faye directrice d'école c'est pas bien
donc on aura des dires directrice c'est
à dire qu'on peut aller encore plus loin
dans la revendication on va dire je sais
pas moi pour est ce qu'on dit la bêtise
c'est fini le centre est sont donc tout
bête
il ya des phrases le bêtise point e
où est ce que je dis c'est à dire que
c'est times bar s'attaquant pas qu'il
repose sur l'ignorance comme les combats
d'ailleurs d'historique de mémoire qui
repose sur l'ignorance de l'histoire de
la langue en fait profondément et repose
sur l'ignorance de l'histoire de la
langue et donc c'est sans fin et vous
aurez toujours plus inclusif que vous
permet c'est une déconstruction de plus
voilà les des constructeurs travaillent
bien sont très efficaces ils ont
quasiment détruit une future détruit le
présent et maintenant ils veulent comme
le passé c'est compliqué ils veulent
détruire l'histoire de notre passé et
l'histoire de notre langue
sur twitter les pros écriture inclusive
disait justement que se féliciter que sa
sortie aussi largement et donc du coup
même ceux qui étaient contre en parler
aujourd'hui du film est alors amants
prépare l'émission je voyais qu'en 1949
la rédaction de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme et les
offres ou svelte et pour que
l'expression mme ann wright soit
remplacer mario mannix pardon aux
etats-unis ont dit pas il faut pas dire
dieu le père c'est dieu le père mère
parce que eh ben oui pourquoi ce sera un
homme on n'en sait rien après tout est
donc enfin il ya plein de domaines comme
certaines et même si cette affaire de
malgré tout deux de d'écriture inclusive
est quand même plutôt française puisque
j'en ai les nôtres genre est justement
vous allez voir que
il y aura des gens en angleterre qui
liront ce scandaleux d'utiliser le
neutre c'est à dire la non
reconnaissance des genres où les alors
raisonnement voyez en angleterre
justement on dit plus chairman non
litscher personne voilà il faut pas
oublier quand même bon alors on est tous
d'accord qu bon il faut pas oublier un
peu la pop et oui la burqa c'est
vraiment pas possible il ne faut pas
oublier quand même que les gens ne se
lève pas tous juste pour le plaisir de
s'énerver et que bien évidemment il n'y
aurait pas de débat si la société
française n'était pas toujours autant
patriarcale et qui évidemment le plafond
de verre qui est une expression vieille
comme le medef existait tout autant dans
pour les salaires pour les postes à
responsabilité et c'est malheureusement
il me semble que ce n'est pas le bon
combat mais ça permet aux gens autour de
cette table de s'énerver à bon compte et
d'oublier qu'ils sont tous des hommes et
pas des femmes et je vous demande bien
pourquoi non pas dans vos magazines et
dans vos écoles à responsabilités vous
n'êtes pas défendre mais non plus que
des femmes
je suis tellement je suis totalement
d'accord maintenant l'assurance je suis
d'accord avec vous et ces messieurs
lessard joie ce que le seul que disait
charles de gaulle et sur la question de
l'islam et l'islamisme la diversité le
grand problème c'est que ce qu'on va mal
là je vous rejoins totalement il n'est
pas le bon combat
c'est à dire c'est que de même que on
voit certains journaux que je n'aimerais
pas qu'ils se battent pour la diversité
et dont toute la rédaction est mal ou
des blanches et donc sa série
c'est là qu'il ya un problème de riez et
moi de temps en temps je me demanderais
sens et je me demande baptisé là je me
demande si elle n'a su représenter
je me demande s'il ya
instrumentalisation rouille et parfois
c'est à dire qu'on va déplacer le débat
sur ça au lieu de poser de vraies
questions de son de son propre pouvoir
et là je vous rejoindrai mais la voyez
ça va très loin non non mais je suis
absolument d'accord c'est une question
de responsabilité individuelle de chacun
avec soi-même qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
voilà c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas aux
mourants le crâne
de nos enfants ou en changeant leur taux
grave qu'on va changer un truc de
société qui profond me semble et y est
pour moi une dernière internet on à
marie dupuis qui est et qui est en train
de nous dire sur les commentaires du
figaro enfin sur la page facebook du
figaro je ne suis pas d'accord ce n'est
pas du féminisme cela permet de voir la
différence en grammaire et de faciliter
leur taux graphe daily française avec
les tories ça reste à prouver
il donne juste deux commentaires de nos
internautes y revenu sur le sujet de
l'université de les facs des étudiants
ariane boucard qui nous dit que pense
monsieur mélenchon sur les frais des
universités suivi des coûts durant
l'année et christophe look et y le fléau
de l'éducation nationale ce n'est pas
les profs mais les rectorats et
l'administration allemande
on vient on évoquait tout à l'heure
merci beaucoup à vous quatre merci à mes
roanne et à toute l'équipe avec qui j'ai
préparé cette émission rendez vous
demain pour un nouveau point de vue
présentée par guillaume roquette
[Musique]